muchas gracias hola bueno ya lo dijeron
y mauricio paredes escritor
y
tengo la suerte de gracias a dios me dio
muy bien mi libro están publicados en
gran parte de hispanoamérica
han sido leídos por más de bastante más
de un millón de niños lo cual a mí me
parece realmente impresionante aunque yo
no logro dimensionar cuánta gente eso
y un trabajo con mi mujer tenemos ahí la
pequeña empresa familiar porque ella es
la que hace las ilustraciones verónica
lemus es la que hace nuestro cenas de
libros y ya demás yo visito muchísimo
colegios establecimientos educativos la
inmensa mayoría de más del 80% son
escuelas de escasos recursos en regiones
y eso es como lo que ha sido más de mil
visitas
me pone súper orgulloso y
quería hablarles acerca de la
exploración y la curiosidad los seres
humanos somos curiosos por naturaleza
somos curiosos en el sentido de que nos
interesan las cosas misteriosas como el
universo cierto los mundos lejanos el
descubrimiento de vida en otras partes
que no sea la tierra pero también somos
curiosos en que somos raros somos
extraños todo ser particularmente yo
acepto deseos como esto de estudiar
ingeniería eléctrica de la universidad
católica se les velan los alambres hace
cortocircuitos y terminada escriben dos
libros para niños
voy a tratar un poco me gusta porque
los seres humanos esto de ser tan
curiosos de querer conocer las fronteras
del universo pero al mismo tiempo esta
búsqueda esta búsqueda de buscar la
frontera universo tiene mucho que ver
con querer conocernos a nosotros mismos
a través de la psicología del
autodescubrimiento de la religión del
arte de todo como hemos visto y los
seres humanos
tenemos esta tendencia de descubrir y de
conocernos a nosotros mismos y lo
contamos a través de historias si
ustedes se dan cuenta la forma en que se
comunican tanto estas charlas como
cualquier tradición es había una vez a
mí me pasó tal cosa cuando yo era niño
descubrí un hueso
quise pintar etcétera contamos una
historia bueno como yo soy muy contreras
no voy a contarles una historia y de
esto en mi presentación prácticamente no
voy a usar de esto no hubiera ni una
sola palabra en la presentación eso es
sólo porque soy muy contra me gusta ir
contra él como buen salmón contra la
corriente
pero primero quería
no son solo letras y palabras 3p como
bueno bonito y barato ya voy a hablar de
que son estas piensas pero tiene que ver
con la perseverancia la paciencia y la
pasión porque en este sentido de
investigar y de descubrir de explorar el
mundo y de conocernos a nosotros mismos
tienen que estar juntas esas tres
características y voy a tratar de
mostrar porque la lectura es un elemento
fundamental chile es una isla nuestro
hogar es todo hogar viene de hoguera
la hoguera lo incentivó literal de la
palabra hogar la etimología viene de
este fuego alrededor del cual se
juntaban las personas a contarse
historias y esta los seres humanos somos
historias desde las leyendas a las
portadas las parábolas que usaban jesús
para explicar cosas muy complejas que
las podía entender desde un niño hasta
el teólogo que se reventaba la cabeza
tratando de entender lo que significaba
hasta los tristes los chistes tienen
gracias en la medida que son ciertos a
nosotros algo nos da risa cuando vemos
una verdad más profunda que la realidad
sin cortar antes circundante lo que lo
que nosotros tenemos alrededor puede ser
muy engañoso está la famosa frase de
antoine de saint exupéry en el
principito entre todo lo esencial es
invisible a los ojos lo que está muy
lejos necesitamos un telescopio y
computadores para verlo lo que está
dentro de nosotros la mente el alma que
se discute si existe o no existe no
sabemos algunos creemos que si otras
personas no entonces esto es que chile
nuestro hogar nuestra hoguera aceptó
calentita que en fuerza está tan lejos
esta isla en que vivimos tenemos el
desierto más árido del mundo por el
norte el cordón montañoso más grande del
mundo cierto por un lado el océano más
grande del mundo por el otro y la
antártica
somos absolutamente una isla no nos cabe
ninguna duda entonces esto estar tan
lejos geográficamente la globalización
nos permite acercarnos
y culturalmente hay un factor que aún
nos distancia y el lenguaje
esta es la misma podría estar en inglés
eventualmente es cierto creative commons
se va a subtitular pero es una
restricción entonces este esfuerzo está
prisma austral que tenemos nosotros por
un lado nos permite una contemplación en
la distancia que es muy favorable voy
hablar de la contemplación y la
reflexión pero también requiere de un
esfuerzo adicional de yo viajé a estados
unidos alemania inglaterra me fui al
doctor a tal parte hice los contactos
con todas las personas requiere un
esfuerzo y esta motivación tiene mucho
que ver con la pasión si yo no tengo la
pasión no voy a tener la voluntad
voluntad acepto viene de burla está la
vocación y vocación viene del latín
vocales y vocales significa llamado
llamado interior llamado de la sociedad
llamado de dios pero la gente que tiene
una vocación siento un llamado yo tengo
que hacer algo yo tengo que hacer esto
en particular a veces un poco
ocurren estos accidentes cierto la
serendipia en donde yo me iba a estudiar
una cosa y terminé estudiando otra
investigaba algo y descubrí algo
lateralmente cierto eso un poco tenía la
intención de ir viajar hacia el oeste y
descubrir un nuevo camino para las
indias y descubrió américa entonces
pueden pasar esas cosas es muy
interesante las 3pm quería mencionar
todo esto de la exploración requiere de
este esfuerzo y en particular requiere
de la reflexión la reflexión en la
actualidad y yo creo que está
subvalorada de la reflexión del tiene
tiempo y requiere de esfuerzo cosas que
están medidas de su valoradas
actualmente el tomarse tiempo evento de
nuevo tomar una decisión y en el
esforzarse en esa decisión no tener una
respuesta inmediata sino que mira dejo
de pensarlo le voy a dar una vuelta sigo
adelante entonces
la reflexión nos lleva a una
responsabilidad yo me hago responsable
de lo que quiero aprender de lo que
quiero conocer de este nuevo
descubrimiento y yo y la lectura en
particular hay una alta relación de la
lectura
todos sabemos que leer hace bien nos
hace más inteligentes no sé mejores
personas pero al mismo tiempo el sistema
obligatorio no ha resultado la evidencia
es empírica de nosotros en chile tenemos
un analfabetismo funcional de más de un
50% es decir la mitad de las personas no
entienden saben leer pero no entienden
lo que leen ni siquiera una receta que
sería como el algoritmo más básico que
uno podría pensar
aproximadamente sencillo en el lóbulo
frontal en particular en el neocórtex
están las funciones ejecutivas las
llamadas funciones ejecutivas en donde
planificamos
queremos conseguir un objetivo y yo
quiero hacer esto quiero entender estas
palabras quiero entender este libro este
el fruto de mi trabajo cierto de 16 casi
17 años está en estos libros para niños
para jóvenes para adultos yo quiero
dedicarme a esto quiero hacer el
esfuerzo entonces
está la planificación yo tomo decisiones
resuelvo problemas tengo la flexibilidad
del pensamiento es decir bueno sabes que
por este camino numeroso todo puede ser
que haya otro entonces es parte de la
función ejecutiva la atención en que me
concentro y en quién no para mí eso es
súper importante de esto yo escribo con
la vía mina y blog este es mi primer
libro que se llama la cama mágica por
tono lo escribimos en este bloque no sé
si la marca existe todavía ni si quiera
no importa mina 072 ve y así funciona yo
después pasó el limpio en computador y
todo pero la base porque escribo a mano
inicialmente porque es lento porque me
obliga a pensarlo más no estar tan
apurado entonces en el lóbulo frontal
está el discernimiento mi visión de la
vida en las observación aumento lógico
deductivo cálculo integral todo eso está
ahí pero lo fantástico que a mí me
parece es que en la literatura y ahora
velarde la lectura literaria se ha hecho
mucha investigación neurocientífica en
torno a la lectura la lectura
informativa y eso pero no ha encontrado
un con respecto a la literatura y en la
imagen que está más distante de mí está
el sistema límbico en una serie de
estructuras en donde están muy
vinculados con las emociones con el
aprendizaje
con el olfato con los recuerdos fíjense
ustedes es cierto el olfato y el olor al
libro nuevo objeto las primeras
experiencias y son satisfactorias nos
llevan a querer mantenerlas y lo que
consigue la lectura literaria la
literatura es juntar precisamente esos
dos ámbitos el sistema límbico donde
está el circuito dopaminérgico la
dopamina el neurotransmisor del placer
me algo me produce placer lo quiero
repetir algo me desagrada no lo quiero
volver a hacer así de sencillo entonces
la dopamina es lo que me lleva a leer
una página tras otra tras otra y hacer
ese esfuerzo porque leer es difícil no
es sencillo es un proceso cognitivo
difícil
en la lectura literaria se juntan
nuestras emociones es lo más básico y
animal el celebro el cerebro reptil con
lo más avanzado y evolucionado de
nuestro cerebro o sea yo tengo
personajes tengo un texto hay argumentos
hay palabras complejas yo tengo un
montón de elementos que tengo que
discernir pero al mismo tiempo siento la
pasión y me entusiasmo y siento que
estoy dentro de ese libro como si fuera
una nueva vida como si fuera un nuevo
mundo
la oxitocina hace que nosotros
quedamos a nuestra protagonista y
lloremos cuando esta protagonista se
muere y sabemos que no existe sabemos
que es de mentira que le mentó una
señora un señor llamado escritora
escritor y lloramos a moco tendido en
cambios vemos las noticias y masacres 60
muertos cierto chuta y claro uno le
afecta pero uno no llora por las sesenta
personas excepto primera persona juanpe
o segunda persona aman a gonzález no no
eso no se hace de esto no tiene ningún
sentido nos volveríamos locos no sería
un acto cuerdo viene una
insensibilización natural ser todos de
frente a las noticias tan tan fuertes
que podemos enfrentar en cambio la
literatura nos ofrece esta oportunidad
de ser un laboratorio de nuestros
sentimientos así como los científicos
tienen el laboratorio para hacer sus
experimentos los libros de ficción la
fantasía nos ofrece la oportunidad de
experimentar con nuestras emociones
nuestros sentimientos las situaciones de
cotidianas y las situaciones imposibles
también
lo que me gustaría que me pasara lo que
me gustaría que no me pasara yo puedo
leer un libro sobre drogadicción sin
hacerme drogadicto yo puedo conocer de
manera vicaria de manera indirecta tener
una experiencia que no podría tener en
la vida real y finalmente me parece tan
interesante esto donde se junta lo más
complejo de nuestra mente en términos
cognitivos con los más complejos en
términos emocionales esto que es en la
lectura literaria está en el valor de la
fantasía a mí a veces me dicen pero tu
carrera ingeniero eléctrico de la
católica cierto porque ese cartón lo
tiene colgado mi papá de su escritorio
ni siquiera lo tengo yo pero
dónde está el valor de la creación
artística en la medida que nos acerque a
la verdad desconocida cierto y no tan
inefable probablemente pero que algunos
creemos que está en alguna parte que yo
no la conozco pero quizás puedo
acercarme con pinceladas con palabras
y hasta el más cuadrado de los
ingenieros dice nuevo para misas que esa
cosa súper linda los cuentos infantiles
pero para los niños yo la fantasía esa
cosa es para otra personas yo soy un
hombre o persona racional del mundo real
y eso es una se queda dormida y sueña
con monstruos y zombies que lo atacan y
unicornio rosado la fantasía está
presente y es señal de cordura si tienen
estos sueños cierto bien excéntrico no
sé si ustedes sabían pero en señal de
que están cuerdos no crean que están
locos y que le pueden contar a demás
personas
entonces pensemos en los niños esta alta
valoración de la lectura
ellos están formando sus recuerdos ahora
en
un núcleo acumbens cierto en el sistema
límbico y en su lóbulo prefrontal están
formando sus recuerdos están teniendo
los primeros olores de lo que va a ser
la vida las primeras experiencias son
muy importantes
todos somos mediadores de la lectura
tanto los creadores como los padres
hermanos mayores
todos somos mejores la lectura entonces
si los niños a través de la lectura
están formando sus primeras experiencias
ojalá que esas experiencias sean
espléndida para que los recuerdos que
tengan de adultos de su infancia sea de
una infancia de maravilla y de fantasía
muchas gracias